[Music]
hi I'm Don V can be Chara and I'm doing
a PhD in geology summer 2019 I interned
with a professional marketing services
group Africa in Nairobi Kenya I was with
them for about two months professional
marketing services group has been around
for more than 20 years
they were mostly into marketing but now
they're also into merchandising in
supermarkets so things like stalking of
products anywhere from milk to satellite
decoders in various supermarket chains
in Kenya and Rwanda I am a geologist so
I study rocks and the earth but on the
site I do computing stuff so almost
every summer I do internships related to
programming
I have interned for large corporations
typically more than 20,000 people with
more system set up already and I was
considering the summer doing something a
little bit different where the role
would involve something less defined
perhaps something where systems aren't
set up as well a little bit like a
startup experience and I did have some
u.s. offers but I think the location was
really enticing and I wanted to
experience not just visit in another
country but really just living there
working there seeing what daily life is
like and what professional life is like
in another culture the company has about
400 ground staff who work in the
supermarket
the way they had been keeping track of
inventory and stalking was through
whatsapp messages so they would message
their manager saying hey today we ran
out of milk or a large piece of our
inventory is now expiring so this is a
huge waste we need less at a man or
lessor supply there was no way of
keeping track of any of this
when PMS group made a report to the milk
company they would have to find pictures
and data by reading through messages so
I made an app to lock all of this every
day and then it's just easy to generate
a monthly excel report about your every
day sale your attendance the employees
can apply for leave inside the app
before what they have to do is come into
the pms office in Nairobi so they would
have to basically take half a day out
travel there
fill out the form for approval from the
manager to take a leave and now that
happens in the app and the number of
days that they did not go to work is
also trapped in a large corporation even
when the same period of time in a period
of two months if you make a change it's
going to be a very very small part of
the system and it won't change the
operations of the organization as a
whole that much while here the impact is
visible so that feels like annoying the
results of what you've done sometimes
you never find out the results like what
you did was it value-adding or not
because you leave after an internship
well here you see the impact the skills
that I learned from this experience are
something that can be applied to
practically any industry so app
development but also product management
and I was always intrigued about it I
thought I wanted to do it but actually
doing it tells you what it feels like on
a day to day basis after doing it I
realized that yes I do love it and if I
ever have to commit to it for a
full-time job for a number of years I'm
glad I did this to know what the role
feels like
one of the hikes we went to was called
mounts of our conservatory it's managed
by the messiah's and we did a 14
kilometer hike just pretty nice fun and
saw this creature created by a volcano
it was so perfectly round and you could
walk on its rim and see the entire room
and then we went into caves that were
formed from its lava tubes and saw a
species of bat that was endemic only to
that place to be able to hide something
from scratch and created completely
yourself it's really fun because then
you can make it exactly the way you want
it considering of course how everyone
else wants it to be but you make it in a
way that you think is the best for the
organization as opposed to just making
tiny changes on something that's already
legacy and you don't want to change the
whole system now so that freshness and
being able to create something from
scratch was just so much joyful
[Music]
you